I'm putting the people on notice that  are coming here from Syria as part of  this mass migration that if I win if I  win they're going back they're going  back I'm telling you they're going back  they're sending people that have lots of  problems and they're bringing those  problems with us they're bringing drugs  they're bringing crime they're rapists  written by a nice reporter now the poor  guy you got to see this guy oh I don't  know what I said I don't remember he's  gonna like how to remember I the old  baby that's what I said  this is a fourteen years ago he still  they didn't do a retraction Donald J  Trump is calling for a total and  complete shutdown of Muslims entering  the United States until our country's  representatives can figure out what the  hell is going on